you guys let's talk about the fact that
you're engaged how in love are you with
each other how did you know this was
right I I mean as I'm pretty solid I
mean I fell in love with Hannah pretty
quickly and I think it's just because
she caught me so off guard with who she
as a person and just how amazing she is
and I couldn't be happier it's the
choosing a five-four was the best
decision I ever made
and I'm just so excited for the future I
was just saying like I wanted sperm
worse before these go if I can pull your
way you did it and I did it
I hate interrupting people
we're in da stuff yeah yeah I think it's
the easiest love it's challenging but
it's also the easiest feeling that I've
ever had and he proves to me every
single day in every single moment that
like he is my person and I it's so crazy
that we like found love on a TV show and
we say that all the time we're like like
we found it in Mexico on a TV show
that's crazy but it just happened and I
can't wait to spend like literally every
single day with him he's great so he's a
gem he's a great guy thank you so much
like it's just stressful duties Chad I
just feel I'm super lucky I mean we know
that you went into paradise wanting
something with Hannah how long had you
been crushing on her before the show
ai ai ai ai was really excited to meet
her I think I did I had some
preconceived notions about her and I
think we're not met her she just
completely blew him out of the water I
mean she's just amazing she's has so
many layers to her and I'm just happy
that everybody kind of is gonna get to
see that even more Hannah Thanks
can we talk a little bit about the
proposal moment because I'm watching it
well you know you said I want my family
to be involved but then you went ahead
and pop the question and you were silent
for a little bit was that like a moment
of just a little bit of confusion or
what was it so I think I was trying to
take everything in because I was like
holy cow this is such a moment like this
is what you dream of when you're little
and then obviously I was really excited
but I think I had something in my heart
where I was like do I go with what my
heart saying or do I have that one thing
which is my family which I know they're
gonna love him then I would like to look
at his eyes and I was like there's no
way I can literally ever say no to this
guy like I know my family's gonna love
heaven and I know I'm gonna do something
for me for once and follow my heart and
that's what this whole entire journey
and experience was for me it was doing
me it sounds like you were almost a
little bit surprised that this like that
you've really found a fiance in paradise
I mean obviously it's a crazy thing but
what do you think I am so excited that
you know we are engaged and that we're
gonna be able to do a lot of cool things
in Mike Taylor in La Follette you
attended a Paradise wedding
could you get married in Paradise she's
she's the gatekeeper of all that
literally such a good answer but
possibly would you consider a TV wedding
I think for us we want that moment to be
super special and if we were to open it
up to everyone else I mean I just don't
know we're gonna take it a day at a time
we're gonna spend a lot more time
together and when we move in together I
think it's gonna start thinking about
you know what date are you moving in the
other ones that having in LA where are
you at San Diego California Matt oh yeah
Cali
san diego's a lot better Hannah you did
get some criticism online for maybe how
your reacted when Dylan was really
clinging to you Dylan you got some
criticism for maybe being too clingy
it's really cool that Dylan was like I
only have eyes for you I'm just scared
because I don't know what's gonna happen
and I don't want him to himself in a
position where he's not open to anything
else happening what do you say that this
is people I I think for me will
definitely not apologize for just being
super head-over-heels for someone and
I'm gonna let him know that's just who I
am as a person and I think for Han I
think she got a lot of unwarranted heat
just because there's like one she was
single to she was 100% upfront with me
at every single moment and I respected
her even more for that and I don't know
I just thought was really unwarranted I
feel like everybody knows what Blake has
done and what he's doing and
like how he's kind of like toyed around
not made up his mind I'm just trying to
wrap my mind around it how someone could
like mistreat a lot of people and not
how did you guys think Blake did tonight
it wasn't maybe the redemption moment I
thought we might get did you think he
should have apologized for more what was
your take on it maybe it just wasn't
received as well but he definitely he he
put it all out there I think it's a
sticky situation like I'm like is there
a winner on either side I don't know I
feel like everybody turns it into that
but it's like it's just it seems like a
sticky situation and I think I don't
know what do you think I'm just hoping
it takes you know whatever you can from
this experience and grows from it let's
talk about some of the struggles that
you had on the show we saw an emotional
Dylan did you worry that you might not
get Hannah at some point I I think for
me I just continue to rely on our
relationship and that's really all you
can do in those moments and kind of just
the operation that she was giving me and
where my head was at and just knowing
that I was gonna fight it until I
couldn't anymore and I just continue to
do that and it worked out and I couldn't
be happier
what do you say to people who said you
were a little obsessive
I think it's funny I mean I I just laugh
at it like I'm sure that you may think
that but Hannah and I couldn't be
happier and in the moment we were so
happy and there's a lot of things you
don't see a lot of conversations that we
had that you don't really get to be a
part of and we were just so connected
and like an emotional and mental and
then obviously a physical level but it
was it was great you both carried each
other literally we carried each other
it was great bonding so you're super in
love would you get married sooner rather
than later I mean are you the one like
yeah I'd do it tomorrow how are things
I'm sure that's what everyone's thinking
that I'm gonna say but no Hannah and I
are just super happy we want to take
every day just as it comes and I think
once we move in together in the future I
think that's when we'll probably start
talking about a wedding
[Music]
[Applause]